good afternoon everyone and welcome to
this week's cfar webinar
on science is the extra strategy this is
a series of virtual talks that we're
hosting
to showcase how research from across
disciplines from
computer science to population and
public health economics and anthropology
can help to inform our public health and
economic response in the wake of covid19
if you don't know us cfar is a canadian
based global research organization and
our mission and mandate really are to
bring
the world's top researchers together
from around the world and across
disciplines
to address important questions facing
society
like many others across the globe cfar
has pivoted quickly to take action on
covet 19
we've launched many new projects new
initiatives and we're highlighting those
through this series my name is alyssa
strome
i'm the executive director of the pan
canadian ai strategy
and the associate vice president
research at cfar
it's my distinct pleasure today to
introduce you to professor kim mcgrail
she is a professor at ubc in the school
of population and public health
and the center for health services and
policy research
she is director of research with ubc
health
she is scientific director of population
health state of bc and i think
um most relevant to our conversation
today she is scientific director of
health data research network
canada welcome kim thank you for joining
us before we begin
today's session i want to let uh take
care of a few housekeeping issues
there goes a truck outside the window uh
today's session will last approximately
30 minutes
kim and i will have a conversation and
then we'll gladly open it up to your
questions please send those questions in
through the q
a function and we'll do our best to
answer as many of them as possible
at the end of our conversation this
session is being recorded and will be
available on the cfar website next week
so let's jump right in kim thanks again
for joining us today it's great to have
this opportunity
to talk to you about the work that you
and your colleagues are doing at health
data research network canada
to coordinate and integrate data across
the country to advance health research
let's start the conversation by having
you describe a little bit about
hdr and canada including its vision
and its partnership model great thanks
for the opportunity it's great to have
this conversation with you today
so health data research network canada
is a
newly incorporated not-for-profit and
it's a pan-canadian network
that is meant to facilitate and
accelerate multi-jurisdictional research
so our network includes data centers and
other organizations
representing all provinces and northwest
territory and we're working on bringing
in nunavut and uconn as well
plus statistics canada and the canadian
institute for health information are
kaihi
and the starting position of our network
and the reason we started working
together
over five years ago well before we had
any funding to actually do the kind of
work we're doing now
is that we we really looked across the
country and see that we have this
position in the world of data where the
glass really is
three-quarters full we've got lots of
strength in
our at the national level and in our
individual provinces and territories
but a lot of difficulty in actually
doing
a good deal of multi-jurisdictional
research and we really felt that if we
had
just the ability to add a little bit
more
we could leverage all of those great
existing resources and
and really promote a lot of more
innovative research
so we're a distributed network and we
have a commitment to distributing
funding we're not creating something
central
we're not trying to create a single
database
across the country and part of that is
because we have a principle of
respecting local context and local
policies
and taking comers as they come
and without demanding that they act a
certain way or be a certain thing in
order to be part of our network
and we're leveraging wherever possible
so we're not trying to build something
new if something
excellent already exists in the world of
data data resources and
access and so on so just very briefly we
have seven objectives overall for our
network
one is to create a data access support
system to help navigate
multi-jurisdictional researchers so it's
one-stop shopping one form
one request process we're working to
harmonize and validate definitions
for important chronic diseases and other
variables so we can have
apples-to-apples comparisons
of data across the country we're
continuing to expand the types of data
that are available
our bedrock really is administrative
data population-based information
but we can link that to cohorts to
surveys
to electronic medical records and other
things as they become available
we're developing technology
infrastructure to improve
the request process but also
documentation storage metadata and other
things really and this is an eye towards
sustainability of the network and the
functions
we're creating supports for advanced
analytics and
infrastructure for data analysis and
really focusing there on distributed
data analysis because we know this is
one of the ways of the future we're
establishing really strong partnerships
with
patients the public and indigenous
communities and this is really around
underlining the ethics of data use
particularly as data resources are
changing so much
and building strong governance to enable
national coordination
ways of working together that we have
the strength from everybody
so you can see that our work really is
around organizing
and making data available the technical
supports around that and really a strong
focus on
ethics and engagement and then of course
transparency and
sustainability it's an amazing
initiative
and it's so incredibly foundational to
our ability to really
uh analyze and assess and understand
uh the impact on health of canadians
across the country and
the work that you're doing is clearly a
huge step forward from where we have
been in the past so just so that we
understand it a little bit more deeply
so
through hdrn researchers can access data
from across provinces and territories
from across different health systems
and even across different data holders
like statistics canada
as i said it's a huge step forward and
so tell us a little bit about
what are the the key advantages for
researchers to having this kind of
broad multi-jurisdictional access why
have we not been able to do that
in the past and what are the remaining
challenges that you're tackling
yeah great question so i you know start
with why
this has been so difficult um and i
really want to start there by
acknowledging that not everything is
difficult some things have really been
done quite well
so kai ha kai hi has a number of
pan-canadian data sets that are
available and have been available to
researcher for quite some time
and statistics canada clearly has
amazing and
rich data resources and and a research
data center network that has
helped researchers get access to those
and of course a
number of provinces have good really
good data and support for access to
those as well
but having said that it has been
absolutely a
really big challenge and really a loss
to all of us that we haven't been able
to conduct
all of the multi-jurisdictional research
that researchers
are trying to propose and put forward
and
pan canadian projects that extend really
just beyond the data of a single
organization that's where we really
struggle
is working together across organizations
i think there's two kind of fundamental
reasons for this
one one is the nature of our canadian
federation um
and the the tension that that kind of
sets up between provinces and
territories and the
and the federal government and i mean
that's a whole political science
conversation but
i i do think it's important to
acknowledge that that is part of what's
going on here
the other is that because provinces and
territories have
the individual responsibility for
delivery of health care and other kinds
of services
the data to collect the way that they're
collected
and the technical systems that they use
to collect the data
even though the services that are
covered are different
and this really creates a challenge for
again the apples to apples comparison
but also
the the ability just to assemble and
then use the data appropriately
so having said all that the the
advantages that
come from addressing this
um it really
are are that we can we can look at that
the effect it's so it's a natural
laboratory in canada we have different
policies and different practices so we
can learn from those
if we can compare across jurisdictions
we can also at a national level look at
the effects of
small populations small small
number of conditions or people who have
had a
relatively um unique service and really
at the pan canadian level for those
small populations that's the only way we
can do some of this research
and so we do still have lots of
challenges including sharing of data
across
boundaries and at this point i'd also
say that we really haven't had enough
engagement with the public
around at the ethical issues of doing
the kind of data linkage and analysis
that we really want to do
great so and i know that you're working
hard on that front
and and you mentioned earlier the work
that you do in
engaging with indigenous communities as
well one thing that just occurred to me
as you were speaking kim i wonder if
um one of the other advantages of
integrating and coordinating
access to data across the country health
data in particular across the country
is really being able to take like full
advantage
of the diversity of the population in
canada which is distributed
across the country do you see that as
another advantage
oh yes i mean and this is probably
highlighted really with the
the covet pandemic and a lot of the
discussion that's been
happening around vulnerable populations
and communities
race-based data and that sort of thing
if you really want to be able to truly
understand
small populations rural populations
certain kind of
racial and ethnic minority populations
it's probably much better to have
a larger group a larger population
being the canadian population to start
from in those cases
great and i know you know from the very
beginning of the pandemic
hdrn you know pivoted very quickly to
say what can we do specifically
to understand and address covet 19 what
can we do to understand how it's
affecting
canadians how it's affecting health
systems and the demand on health systems
can you give us a couple of examples of
what hdr
and did to address covenant is doing to
address covid and also maybe some of the
specific projects that researchers are
leveraging
uh the hdr and data network in order to
address
yeah let's uh we did recognize early on
that there was
a role for us even as in a starting
point of sharing information
making researchers aware and in one spot
similar to what we've done in other
cases of what data might be available
in which provinces that could support
covid research now in the first instance
that meant documenting where
coveted testing data were going to be
available for research access
and what other kinds of data sets that
those could be linked
to and so we started we put together it
was weekly
at first and we've gone to a little bit
more
less frequent updating of a briefing
note just to describe where we are the
new features that are available
and just more recently i think it's just
today that came out where
we have been working on metadata for the
covid data
and in the coming months i expect that
that will be increasing focus on the
other
data sets that we might be able to link
as we start to think about
research on the um broader effects of
covid
beyond the people who've had the pen or
have had the virus to thinking about the
broader effects on communities and
individuals um
and at this point of course there's no
projects that have gone through the
whole process and been
completed through the hdrn supports but
we've been working with
a lot of researchers on pursuing
potential topics or studies they might
want to do
and working with some specific ones on
on
funded projects now ranging from
emergency department use
and in that case we're working with a
team that's actually assembling a new
data set that will be available to
others as well
and to virtual care reproductive care
and pregnancy outcomes
so the wide range of things sort of the
the full spectrum of what
what we can do with the the data that we
have i know as a
sort of an interested stakeholder in the
ecosystem i've really appreciated
getting
your covet 19 briefing notes on a
regular basis to
just maintain my awareness about what's
going on and what's available
for researchers so that i can share it
amongst my community as well
uh i think we're uh just about ready to
head into questions so i just want to
let the audience know that we'll head to
questions
after uh our next topic of discussion so
if you've got questions please put them
into
uh the q a box for us and we'll get to
them right away but the last
topic that i want to touch on sort of
formally with kim
is the fact that over the last year she
and i have worked together and had the
opportunity to work with
15 other leaders from across the ai and
health
research innovation ecosystems in a
national
ai for health task force and what we've
been doing
is developing a series of
recommendations to both the federal
government
and provincial and territorial
governments towards
a national ai for health strategy the
report of the ai for health task force
which we've titled building a learning
health system for canadians
is now available on the cfar website so
kim
let's hear from you a little bit about
why you think it's so important that we
have a national strategy
on ai for health and how it will deliver
benefits to canadians
we really appreciate being able to talk
about this because it was such a
pleasure to
work as part of that task force and you
produced a
fantastic report so congratulations on
that so
i i mean i think it's important to start
just from the the basics
of ai and just my perspective on this is
ai has like many technologies probably
like any
technology at all has a great potential
for good
um but equally can be used to produce
harm and
it could be unintended consequences
still harm
in addition ai is one of the drivers is
what has been described
as the fourth industrial revolution and
should be kind of summarize what i think
people are talking about when they see
this is it's this kind of
continuation of the digital revolution
that's kind of starting to blur
the the distinctions between or to kind
of combine
physical biological and um computing
kind of processes so
um man and machine kind of a framework
of things
so in other words it's expected that ai
is going to be really disruptive
um it to business to government
government to governance
um into our daily lives and if we
believe this
then i think is really important that we
have a coordinated strategy
first of all to make sure that we truly
understand what's happening
and both the unintended and intended
consequences and that we have a handle
on how
best to make sure that we get good
things out of ai
and secondly that we um uh mitigate
any negative consequences if we if we
are able to do so
so then if we think more specifically
about health and the health care system
in canada it makes sense for us to focus
on health in part i mean we have a
ongoing abiding respect and love for our
universal health care system with all
its imperfections it is still a great
building block and hopefully we can
continue to make improvements in that
the ai approaches in health can
accommodate a large amount of data
including images they can help us make
sense of this vast quantity of
information it can improve efficiency
and diagnostics and ai systems
and can be used to augment human
activities so they can
help make providers provide better
services
but they also could do things like help
people live in their
homes for longer and and augment those
informal and formal supports as people
age
so ultimately i think we need a pan
canadian strategy
in ai for health because it is a
disruptive potential
of this technology because of the
changes
in the infrastructure that are needed
for ai are significant
um and because ai and health is
ultimately a global issue
and if we want to to have some influence
on that at a global level we need to
work
in a pan-canadian way yeah absolutely i
think
you know on that last point one of the
things that we discussed a lot at the
task force of course we talked a lot
about data and data access
you'll recall and and other members of
the task force i see are on
this webinar in the audience today we
spent an inordinate
amount of time talking about data and
data access and you know the pandemic
has really
um actually allowed us as a research
and innovation community to make some
important steps and
hdrn has really been leading the way on
that
um but the other thing that we spent a
lot of time talking about
at the task force was really you know
canada's opportunity around the
application of ai to health
and our specific opportunity because we
are you know a great leading ai nation
we have tremendous expertise in this
field across the country
because we have such strong values
around
ai and its use in a responsible and
ethical manner and especially
when we're talking about health and
we're talking about personal data
those principles and values are so
incredibly crucial
but also the opportunity you know to
really leverage that publicly funded
health system that we have and the fact
that the data
is and should be and can be made
available for
research and innovation so um you know
it was
such a such a wide-ranging conversation
and we probably could have had
a hundred recommendations in our report
and we worked so hard to really
narrow them down on the focus of the
things that we felt as a committee
uh were essential first steps in moving
canada forward to really
take advantage of all this and and
bottom line being
you know better health for canadians i
think that's the vision of the task
force so thanks to you for
all of your contributions to to that
work and as i said we've got a couple of
members of the task force i can see our
on our participant list today so thanks
to everybody
for their efforts so let's move to the
audience questions now
and we'll start with a quick one
actually from uh randy gable
uh a colleague of ours on the task force
from
the university of alberta and from amy
our
ai institute in edmonton really quick
question randy asks
is there an earl that provides
information about
research access to health systems covet
test data
randy i think what you're asking for is
how do you find out
uh what data is available about code
testing
through hdrn and the answer to that is
you can go to the hdrn
website and it's all on there and look
for their briefs as well and the brief
today actually
speaks to the metadata that's available
okay so another question that's come in
um
the participant asks what are the most
expected
worries regarding data sharing from the
population
and data owner so really the concern
that citizens have and the concerns that
the public have
about data sharing can you outline some
of that for us can please
sure you know this is a
it's a difficult question to answer in
part because i don't want to pretend to
speak on behalf of
all canadians what i can speak to is the
existing literature that
has resulted from a pretty deep public
deliberation
and including focus groups but longer
deliberation sessions as well and
i have been leading some of those in in
british columbia but there's a
international group of people who've
been working in this area and
interestingly there's quite a lot of
consistency across countries
from what we can see in this so people
are really really open to having their
data
used for research um but it's always
in context with provisos and those
provisos really
revolve around this uh the five safes
framework um and this this is a
framework that's been
emerging as just it doesn't say what
needs to be done
but it tells you what you need to think
about and what those things are
is safe people so who is it that's
acting
accessing the data and people have a lot
of trust for
researchers university-based researchers
they start to get
a little more concerned if we're talking
about private industry
and it's not i don't want to say that
it's a hard no it's just that it changes
the conversation a bit and there's
different considerations
so safe people is a big one safe
environments where are you going to be
doing
the research and increasingly people
expect things to be done in a controlled
secure environment because that just
says that you've got greater control
over what's happening
um safe projects so what is the question
that's being
asked and who's vetted it to say that it
has scientific merit and will produce
some public value
safe data so this is the uh how
identifying are the data that are going
to be used and have things been done to
at least remove direct identifiers names
and addresses and things like that
and safe outputs what's coming out
what's going to be shared publicly
is there potential for harm to come to
individuals or communities
small populations based on that so those
are the things that that the public
worries about
less less blanket or strict yes or no
and more um what's being done to protect
data
and put some guard rails around use
great and uh that five saves framework i
found
in researching this field and working on
the task force was really such
an excellent conceptual model to think
about
what are the things that we have to be
concerned about what are the questions
that we need to be asking ourselves as
researchers
as we're we're considering the use of
individual data
so along the same lines we have a
question that came in from another one
of our participants
about the type of work that you're doing
around community public and patient
engagement
so he asks you to speak more to
community patient
engagement in the hdrn and how that
interfaces with the idea
that individual patient participant
consent is not required in studies of
administrative data
thank you he says yeah great great
question because of course
again the bedrock not all of the data
that we have is this
what we call unconsented data but a big
portion of it is
and and they're unconsented in the sense
that there's allowances for
use of these data in the absence of
consent
um again with the guard rails
around that so when we are talking about
public
and patient engagement in health data
research network canada
we're really we're really focusing on on
data specifically and i contrast that
with the broader strategy for patient
oriented research from cihr which is
what we're funded under
so we're not um so this really is a
focus on
on how are we going to use data what
should we what kind of data should we be
bringing in
and what are the limits to allowances
for research uses of that information
and so we're we have established
an interim public advisory council for
hdr and we're just in the process of
recruiting and filling out a permanent
structure for that and we will be
looking to that group for helping us um
with a number of things one is
communication so we really feel that
transparency is kind of the first order
of business for
the activities that hdrn is doing but
another is really to help
truly create a space where the public
has an influence on the policies
around data use um and then i think
we're gonna
we well we will absolutely take
direction from that advisory committee
on
other things that we should be
considering um
whether that's about information flows
or about doing things differently and
and i do want to emphasize that that we
i i personally feel
very committed to the fact that the
public needs to have a true say in this
this is not just
a pr communications exercise absolutely
and it can't be
uh tokenism in any way it has to be
really deep
engagement consideration collaboration
with the public and with patients and
and we articulated that very strongly in
the task force report very much taking
um inspiration from the work that you've
done at hdrn and that others have done
across the country on this topic really
thinking about
um the role of citizens
in understanding and contributing to
this work going forward
i i was always inspired by uh the uk
where they seem to have a very strong
culture of data trust and i think that's
something that we can learn a lot from
and aspire to build in canada this
culture of
inclusion uh within the governance
within decision making
around data and that's you know that's
how you engender trust and how you're
able to
advance uh research objectives another
couple of quick questions about
hdrn another colleague asks are there
any plans to reach out
beyond our boundaries to coordinate with
other countries
yes as a matter of fact we have
a partnership around covid with the
uk health data research group um
and we're working on a memorandum of
understanding for larger work with them
in fact we're working with them on
metadata now because uh
that with with the idea being that
metadata being that how we describe
the data that we have if we can align
metadata then we are
effectively aligning the potential for
international
collaborative research projects so we're
working with them so that we can
and get those things in place now okay
such a great partner for us because they
have so many similarities in their
health system
in their principles values democracy
um and have been a real leader in this
space so i think the uk is always a
great example to look to
yep uh last question about hdrn and then
we'll start to wrap up
uh for provinces who are looking to
build
their own internal capacity for data
collection and sharing
can or does the hdrn assist them in
accelerating
those improvements that's such a great
question
yeah it's one of the things that we have
found over the last couple years of
really working together more formally
it's
one of the greatest assets we can
provide is the
all the learning and information from
the existing centers to share
with those who are trying to start up
but honestly
equally it goes in the other direction
as well so we have a established a
for example a privacy working group of
all the privacy leads from our
organizations across the country and
they're helping to do
a number of things on a legislative
review and and that sort of thing so
absolutely those resources are there and
we're really open to
helping as we can awesome
so this has been a fabulous conversation
thank you kim for joining me today it's
been
gone by very quickly as as these always
do and i'm afraid we don't
have time for any further questions i
want to remind the audience
that the ai for health task force report
is now available on the cfar website
and before you sign off i'd like to
thank everybody for joining us today for
this conversation and i'd especially
like to thank you kim for telling us the
story of hdr in canada and
the amazing foundation that it has laid
to
integrate and coordinate data across the
country and make it available
for research cfar's virtual talk series
continues
on august 20th with cfar president dr
alan bernstein in conversation with
professor arturo
casa devel from the johns hopkins school
of medicine and he's doing
groundbreaking work on the use of plasma
for the prevention and therapy of covet
19 i hope that you can join us then
please visit our website cfar.ca to find
out more about the series and to view a
recording from today's talk which will
be
posted early next week thanks again to
everybody for joining
us and have a wonderful afternoon
bye-bye